yo words of everybody prestige here
again and we gots more mr. survival BAM
apologies is too little late I know but
you know we'll get to it and were told
you wanna you wanna load bro so I was
able in my intermission to get some fogs
so now we have six workshops and more
pork chops to cook up that beef so we'll
have that cooking and we're going to go
on an adventure to the rest of the messe
and at the same time as our adventure
we're going to click blocks for building
so let's just make yourself a nice
little staircase down make sure we just
get just get all these blocks and just
just just want to get a little box let's
staircase yourself down a little more so
yeah tanning view that are new to this
which I would be surprised but this is
I'm just go looking at some of the new
biomes of 1.7 and I'm doing a little
survival in to the violence I'm going to
be getting an accumulative more stuff in
each bottom so this is my first biome so
I have that much stuff so I why I'm
going to hardcore let's get some sand
horse up some more pics more yellow of
course one yellow I do I really like the
color scheme that they did with the UH
with the actual play like I think they
nailed it down I don't know it was like
geographically correct but I know it
looks pretty nice look at that like that
mountain the mountain looks beauteous so
we're gonna go so I think I feel like
sir at certain layers it's supposed to
be certain block colours the majority of
the time like so wherever this layer is
there's a lot of this normal just
straight-up hardened clay this later
there's a lot of brown next play up here
there's a lot of yellow that seems to be
kind of the gist all those want pic
I feel like I'm gonna run out of pics
made more oh well want to try the music
down just a bit music and sounds music
twelve percent it's a little bit don't
you think yeah I think so so this volume
would basically all we just got the good
ole is that's red right red Sinclair
yeah lots of that good ol red stuff this
biome is mainly well it is only just
it's a lot of interesting features and
mountains and a lot of clay as you can
tell and so the other biomes I saw one
it's like red road trees another one's
like like a like that like I don't like
like like like ice I don't know if
that's a real one but it'll look real so
yeah this one then we have the top layer
of dirt instead of like and like just a
lot of dead dirt since it's clay ground
so obviously you're going to love that
dirt and playground have a lot of grass
usually grown and clay who is this a cat
now this is in cave so they have some of
these tricky catcher caves which are
dirty bro that very dirty if I do say so
myself see I just want to make sure we
get good amount of all the types of clay
because then we can make our final house
all beautiful with all this clay then
we're going to be getting a ton of
normal no just hardened clay but I'm
gonna say these bio this bottom at least
does look at very very nice its own eco
overview someone looks a bit different
or maybe that's just in contrast to the
bright colors of the clay that could be
mine just playing tricks with me could
be bro who knows ooh spoiler alert this
video probably won't have a intro or an
outro just because I'm going to be
uploading the right after I record it
and I'm we're going to now our frat
scores that amazingly high
uh amazingly high I don't even know what
the word it's what the heck it records
just like crazy like the file size the
file size is that as France records that
are huge like I could do this entire
video at ip5 gigabyte five or ten
gigabytes and that's like the low end
like when I play battlefield 4 and I
just record a video 0 0 / 0 gets so
large that's what she said inappropriate
jokes are funny because they're
inappropriate okay so we got a new
bottom over here and we got some like
pillars are like clay in the water let's
let's decimate when these pillows wah
wah wah wah all those out of this pic
should probably start heading back ow
dang it well I can get some sand I only
have that much that's red this is very
not read stand it's like the same colors
don't understand clay whoa but um yeah
so I still haven't found out how to make
stained glass if someone was leave it in
the comments below how do you make
stained glass I'll be I would appreciate
a lot because I have no idea how to make
it I feel like I'm gonna forget by the
end of this video to go search it up how
do i just go search it up so yeah that's
a thing I feel like if I cook red sand I
should get red glass but its own that
would only suffice for the color red I
still have I have no coal I really need
coal but I want to spend my time on you
know was just my time in these new
biomes okay that's in Cold Mountain so
we'll go pick up that coal and I guess
oh yeah oh my gosh guys o.o chickens
that that's some meats chickens give me
a goods getting the goods from all
chickens I had a saddle I tame a Bronco
but don't have saddle so I can't tame
Bronco see how they also added like it
tons of new like flowers so we're gonna
this is a UH and observe observe bluet
if that's like French or something i'm
pronouncing it wrong my bad
yeah I know it's gonna get that cold
let's use a pork chops and we should
have enough time to get it back home Oh
more coal husband docomo that's what I'm
talking about son Wow Stone just breaks
cold the fastest speeds ever gosh this
is so slow I hate it I hate you some
stone pickaxe you suck but i did a
little slow pick up so we can you expect
another I can satisfy your needs that's
right something x you suck oh you also i
picked up some more so that's good let
me block you with some stained clay
that's what I'm talking about we'll jump
that's what I'm talking about this pick
is probably gonna break in this cold
pocket yeah you I'm gonna have to use
some blocks to just tunnel up to get
back to my house so this probably going
to be my second episode second dental
appt will obvious is my second episode
since I had a first episode before it
but um this is probably going to be my
last message survival so there goes
Geronimo what barely other water that so
let's try making it home and then we'll
see we'll probably just start packing up
make some more tools all that jazz tons
of sand however I already have I almost
have a stack his hand so we don't need
no more stand almost and for us all
right I'm gonna have to make this whole
thing right I really need to change my
skin back to my a classic hair braid
hunter since right now this little
Samuel Jackson as you can tell about it
you're the classy suit and black man
hand dupa dupa put a bit of bitter
bitter bitter but but it is probably
copyrighted okay did
but I'm talking quieter that might be
just a natural thing because it is
lateish sent 40 my house sound a late
but it's late-ish and I think pretty
sure Bolton parents are sleep so just
don't wanna like wake them up and piss
small you know try them at all well then
that was a terrible jump all right Rik I
can do this to show you who or go who no
help no oh dang it all you know what
what can I spit why I can definitely
spark also however I need more
cobblestone to make a pic I'll save this
cobblestone I can spare what can I spend
I got why I get so much like great let's
see let's just tell myself up a little
bit like grey be very conservative about
it if I ever don't need to use any don't
use any let's break some dirt and then
for dirt save my goods good put up I'll
just do that alright so we made it to
the top of this mountain oh crap the Sun
is setting no oh oh we're gonna go
around that instead of going under ow
bad gravity making me hurt myself and
stuff that ain't nice naw see we did
have white yeah bite but did it too dude
you see the messages does look just very
and looks nice it does have a desert e
Oh snowball my went the wrong way I
think mom's gonna be way more to the
right because i do not remember snow by
whom oh here's one pass my house my good
chunk
and I don't mean that literally because
that would be a good chunk literally
would not you wouldn't even be that much
in this game rip wouldn't it's only 16
by 16 I would not to go deep for it's a
lot of blocks because you just get such
high multiplies but if you're just going
off like length and width or length and
depth not height not up and down oh gosh
mild responded all right sort out come
on house where are you oh gosh oh gosh
let's buy just gonna want my blood no
blood for you spied up skeletons go on
my blood oh crap crap crap Oh babies I'm
no baby zombie babies under be zombies
are too fast to two trains no no two
chains oh gosh 2 chainz truthfully oh
gosh the mouse house keys oh yeah house
or just gotta get past the line of
creepers all spiders going ham up in
here orbs amies nope nope nope nope nope
nope just get to that scoffs good today
oh haha mother truckers am i normal so
you can't do nothing to me you can't do
nothing to me they do do you can't do
nothing to me but it didn't eat do do do
do you can do not give me a beer dude
sua kill the creeper also art so this is
just getting all my good do it did the
day you can have a problem I don't have
any calls on work good thing what want
blood on the back good thing I came
prepared so I have one pic at least for
the journeys alright then we really
gonna want to take our furnace
and crafting no crafting a look I'm
going to build what know that want to
build myself no bed there we go I bell
muscles bed place a bit damn right here
that is a little butchy all life center
monsters nearby Daniel screaming
monsters it's like there's like two
zombies whatever all right guys well but
o ye all right I hope you all enjoyed
this video of message survival my next
video will probably be um bred 4s
redwood for survival or Iceland survival
or something of the sort so be looking
again looking for that um tell me how to
make clothes hand cut glass and you know
actually wait wait wait I did are you
gonna solve this once and for all okay
to make red glass at red sand oh Oh Oh
guys guys oh oh gosh oh that's why i
right screw seeds I want the dirt though
nope already tried that and I just I
just wasted it I apologize but all right
so guys tell me out of my college hand
arm you got any survival saved
rejections or series suggestions leave
in the comments down below since I
remove I I don't know what I want to do
for the next series after this mess
survival's so yeah um that's about it if
you enjoyed this video they've made it
to the end you muscle like this video so
leave the like I don't really appreciate
yeah sorry guys peace out